a
[Music]
and
continue to kill this Saturday it closed with
an official death toll of 62, which is
something that we as Salvadorans
cannot allow, we cannot really
allow, and that is why we are here to
not let this go.
decision that these delinquents
have made
i
[Music]
and whoever has tried it is good because
notice that there is too much violence
many of them are causing more
calm but that is already for revenge is
against the government
[Music]
and
no no
or
why
[Music]
In the current crisis,
good sense of wisdom is required, not
political bullying or advertising demagoguery,
to put aside the disastrous manipulation of
public opinion and keep the country
within the constitutional state of
law.
[Music]